there's nothing I'd rather do than work
a 15-hour day you need to not buy a
fresh hoodie you may need to move into a
new apartment I'm being dead serious
what I'm good at now people you know
it's so right
I'm good at timing the motivation watch
a top 10 with the lead nation
he's Gary Vaynerchuk and here's my take
on his top ten rules a success vol 17
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have self awareness outside of
spending time with my inner family and
closest friends and outside of garage
selling and watching the Jets there's
nothing I'd rather do than work a 15
hour day yourself or you know you and I
always have this why I shoveled snow and
did lemonade and I washed cars as a
seven-year-old all day long on August
9th cuz it's what I like and I'm not
gonna judge somebody who wants to work
9:00 to 5:00 be on 13 softball teams and
play video games all day and make 42k
year if she and he are pumped as they're
equal to me because I know a bunch of
miserable millionaires and I know a lot
of unhappy 55k a yours and everything in
between
rule number two give I literally get 700
emails a month when somebody knows I'm
gonna be in some town like Gary like in
the title like great news I will pick
you up from the airport
and drive you to your hotel I want to
really give I'm like you I'm like that's
$48 uber ride I need my peace and quiet
to catch up with the work when I land
from the flight you don't want to give
me a ride you want me to give you
consulting for 45 minutes while we drive
you can save your lunch that you want me
to buy that you want to buy for me and
all that and I'm fascinated by you know
and a lot of times I'll hit up those
kids they're like yo it's not working
I'm like cuz you're not giving when
you're deeming somebody you're asking
you're trying to take like you know it's
it's really it's a really funny thing to
try to get somebody to click on what the
definition of giving is and people
struggle with selflessness they really
do they leave they struggle with not
being selfish in the disguise of giving
and i think ii think the reason i want
to talk about it and keep throwing out
these examples is once you're aware of
it people aren't even oftentimes aren't
aware you know but once you become aware
of it i actually think it changes the
entire framework of this conversation
rule number three don't worry what
others think
I'm not perfect but I'm gonna be you to
say just go this move
you're bound you're valuing other
people's opinions my question is why do
you look so sharp do you love it or do
you think it's reject something to other
people you've got a break you've got to
figure that out the only reason people
overthink is thing cuz they worry about
the judgement
I go fast because I don't for real like
real what am i doing fast but only one
thing that I'm just really really
knowing grass and you should do it and
if you don't know it
hedge it upfront you can start a video
it's like wow thank you so much doing
the game if you're not doing nothing's
happening talking and thinking rule
number four don't be delusional
so you talk patience to write that
people should be patient in in the
pursuit of their goals at what point
does patient just become delusion a lot
of times oh so what are the hacks or the
tips that you for them to be self-aware
to know when to just why don't when is
patience just right or have you been
running the same thing for seven years
and nothing good has happened you're
delusional
let's start there that's a test I
believe in that if there's been no
progress in your rap career or in your
art or your video blog and you've been
doing it every day for seven years as
hard as you can and nothing has happened
the market has spoken that's one way now
is that four years is that two years do
people jump off like you need to see
some level of progress to keep you
having blood in the water to get you
going but sometimes there is a
breakthrough because if the machine is
in between you and the market well then
you got to be discovered but the reason
now I think it's more pure is because
SoundCloud and Spotify and YouTube and
Shopify and Amazon now you get the
feedback loop so fast and it isn't the
arbitrary subjective call the reason
that took some of the greatest stars of
all time eleven years to break through
is because other people had say people
didn't see Gaga's talent they shook
thought she was weird somebody thought
she wasn't weird she breaks out AG Lady
gaga today she goes on YouTube and
Spotify direct and the market speaks
quicker people are more famous quicker
now if they have the talent cuz nobody's
in the middle this is why I talk in
general terms on content of course cuz I
don't have the context but if somebody
sat here and I listen for 40 minutes I
would tell them if they're delusional or
just impatient and most people are
impatient and delusional
also if you want to learn how to build
confidence checking my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link is
in the description below the reason
people aren't patient is they value
other people's opinions too much rule
number 5 chase happiness if I can
replace the word millionaire with happy
and I'm crazy I think I can pull it off
what do you do Gary 1 let's say you're
at a location or you're a point in your
life that you're obviously you need you
need to pay bills but you're no longer
happy what what are you you need to
change your bills ok ok you need to not
buy a fresh hoodie you may need to move
into an apartment I'm being dead serious
one of the other conversations I'm
having is change your bills ok you know
if you're not happy but you got bills
why don't you look at your bills
happiness no dude it's everything rule
number 6 be honest I think getting a
sense of like what are you actually up
to is super important and if you're like
I love what I do well then you should
invest in that beast forever if you're
like I just want some money and buy a
home in Jamaica and live there well then
maximize it and squeeze it I think it's
a very important thing I just don't
think most people know what they're
doing when I say know what they're doing
I mean macro like why do you have this
business correct and it doesn't need to
be a super complicated answer it's a
lifestyle business this is a legacy is
this you want to make as much money as
possible flip it and do something else
like if you are honest with yourself and
everybody around you employees will work
for you if you tell them that you're
gonna drive everybody into the ground
and flip it because some of them may say
well I just need the Paycheck or they
may say oh cool I want to be in flipped
or cool I just want to watch her do it
and then maybe I'll do it like truth
really is good it's really really good
rule number 7 take action
people like listen to your content and
consume it they'll like the feeling of
being motivated but then there's work
that has to be done after it and I don't
think people like that feeling yeah and
I think that's why I talk about trying
to find things you like not making money
the variable of happiness you know this
like I make content that literally says
stop watching me go do it and then they
go and watch somebody
house that charges them for the
information so like yeah I mean like
people what people like consuming
motivational content because they think
they're actually doing something I think
it's like watching somebody else work
out rule number eight being good at
timing I will tell you the biggest thing
that I've gotten better at the lessons I
learned as a kid even though I was right
I literally built my dad's entire
business strategy from Wine Library when
I took over ninety nine eight I'm not
the this this is true that by the year
2000 which is twenty four months from
then everybody would walk into our
liquor store with a phone and have
technology that would give them the
price of every product in the country in
order of best price and that's literally
how I decided to sell everything a cost
that anybody knew and then build up
other brands it was great because it
really worked because we were the price
leader of every wine anybody wanted we
still don't do that
it is now 2019 we have closest
capability we have that capability ish
there is something called wine searcher
if you're a big wine buyer that
aggregates like it it's there but it's
not one person will walk into wine
library this year that's by where people
look up stuff on Amazon you know so I
was wrong about timing what I got bet
what I'm good at now people you know so
right I'm good at timing that's why it
in bed on VR that's why I don't bet on a
are that's why I don't bet on machine
learning or things of that nature
I know every one of those things is
gonna happen the question is when rule
number nine learn to deal with
negativity I like reading my negative
comments way more than my positive ones
I mean it I mean it and I don't think
there are trolls and haters I really
don't I think that they've consumed me
in a context and I need to be thoughtful
about what they're thinking now I do
believe I equally believe that if you're
taking time to consume people's other
people's content on the internet and
then you have the energy to leave
terrible comments you're cut you're in a
sad place yourself you know so usually
when I read like Gary Vee you're a snake
oil salesman my first default is okay
why do they interpret this taught
zwei but even before I go there my alpha
even before that my first default is
like I feel bad for that person and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is turn adversities
into strengths here
if you say I did poorly in high school
cuz my parents there's something
interesting you may in hindsight in
years to come when you get older see it
as a huge advantage when I hear stories
of that much adversity the amount of
people that I know that have gone on to
shine first of all for you to be this
young and have the aspirations to break
through instead of dwell and be like I
got it's over huge I think if you keep
building on that and like I actually
think being bad at high school is
foundationally a core reason most people
end up being successful and so the more
you start thinking about your
adversities as strengths the more the
reality of what you're trying to achieve
is gonna happen I've got a special bonus
cut from Gary on how to mark it properly
that I really think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching video to taking
action here we go question number one
what adversity of yours do you need to
turn into us strength number two what
action are you sitting on that you need
to do something about right now and
number three what is chasing happiness
look like for you there's a big
difference between something being dead
and something not being a good deal the
actions you're running your business
whether it's Yellow Pages our Direct
Mail or even Google AdWords for a lot of
people is not a good deal anymore as it
used to be to me when I think about
marketing or what I'm about or why I'm
pushing you to post organic content on
Instagram right now and run ads on
Instagram is because I think in 9 years
it's the Rams not going to be a good
deal it'll still be here guess what
myspace is still here marketing and
running a business is about having a
good deal on your media spend your
efforts in your time not if something is
dead or alive this is in the margins
this is in the arbitrage is it worth it
today February 2019 are your actions of
worth it today or do they work in 2003
and you're just on that repetitive
if you want more garyvee check out the
first top ten rules I made on him the
link is right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
you need to bet on your strengths and
don't give a [ __ ] about what you suck at
if you want this if you want bling bling
if you want to buy the Jets if you want
to do work